les camions envahissent les abords du
village malgré les interdictions
[Musique]
pour les voir arriver et leur dire de
partir cette partie de la commune s'est
transformée en décharge à ciel ouvert à
cause des détritus laissées par des
routiers regarde là-bas
voilà ce qu'on trouve voilà
régulièrement sur les bords de route
partout regarde les bouteilles du Rhin
là regardez c'est pas du jus d'orange et
je préfère pas savoir ce qu'il y a dans
les sacs poubelles qui sont fermés
spécial sur ça
ils sont en galère quand même
je connais ça ils sont dit à la Coupe du
Monde on va mettre des sujets on a quoi
en stock là il y a les routiers qui
pissent dans les bouteilles
on l'a depuis
la Coupe du Monde personne nous regarde
là je vous dis la vérité sortez tout ce
qu'on a la déstocker là Raymond tu as
pas dormi depuis combien d'années
non mais soyez ça va tu me reconnais ça
va oui alors oui c'est malhonnête là les
détritus qu'on voit c'est pas de la
semaine dernière et c'est pas dit à 15
jours ça date d'au moins d'un an six
mois lave ta ville déjà pour commencer
si vous voulez faire un reportage
faites-le correctement moi j'ai regardé
ce reportage alors je veux bien qu'on
dise je comprends que les gens disent
les camions c'est dangereux ils roulent
n'importe comment il y a des Espagnols
il y a des Turcs qui a des pneus il y a
des Romains il y en a d'autres je suis
d'accord je suis d'accord sauf que ils
ont élargi les Nationales donc les mecs
veulent pas les payer 100 € de péage si
tu peux faire gratuitement tu fais 15 km
en plus le problème c'est que tu dis on
veut pas de camion étranger sur nos
routes mais nous on va aussi sur les
routes étrangères et on paye pas quand
on va sur les hautes étrangères donc
comment tu fais quand tu arrives au
resto tu es content d'avoir ton entrepôt
tu es content d'avoir tes frites quand
tu vas chez Ikea tu es content d'avoir
tes meubles quand tu vas au supermarché
tu es content d'avoir de la bouffe
quitte la ramené ça quitte la ramené
quand tu construis ta maison tu as
ramené tes fenêtres on n'a pas ramené
son Vélib' donc je veux bien qu'on dise
on arrête les camions pas de problème et
on va sur des camions électriques là on
est en train d'aller sur des camions
électriques c'est très bien
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
du camion électrique qui jette moins de
bouteilles de jus d'orange
c'est pas du jus d'orange ne le bois pas
tu vas avoir des affaires
il y a quand même un fléau des camions
on a des villages qui sont traversés par
2000 camions par jour mais oui Cyril
c'est un fléau
c'est la double voie qu'ils ont fait sur
les Nationales du coup maintenant tu
peux rouler à 80 et il y a des maisons
qui étaient construites avant il y avait
pas autant de camions parce que ça prend
Léo
raquette sur l'autoroute tu dois faire
600 km
il est là frérot on est la route il faut
repousser les maisons c'est tout
c'est une question hyper importante à
poser notre secrétaire vous conduisez
avant on aurait ce que vous aviez le
permis c'est très drôle que vous me
posiez je vous en avez parlé non en fait
j'essaie de passer mon code de la route
depuis plusieurs fois sans succession on
en avait parlé le code notamment hein
les cours de conduite j'arrive à
conduire mais le code je n'arrête pas
d'échouer et c'est très frustrant parce
que vous entendez tout le monde qui sort
de la salle et ça fait ouais je l'ai une
faute et vous êtes là ouais dans la
semaine le code c'est un enfer et quand
il passe le truc comme ça il passe
toujours le truc comme ça et il faut
quand même et toi tu es dégoûté tout
c'est vrai que tout le monde là en plus
moi je l'ai pas eu moi le code
j'ai dû le repasser parce que moi
j'avais plus de points j'ai dû repasser
le code mais non ah ouais thalass
j'aurais visé le soir ça me rassure un
peu rassurez-vous alors je peux vous
dire non mais je préfère cent fois la
conduite le code c'est très dur et qui a
passé le permis bateau
c'est compliqué
quoi on était un peu des vedettes
faisaient des courses de voitures et il
y avait un morceau faut pas faire sur
une rivière donc on était obligé de
passer un truc et on a tous fait ça oui
oui non non et le mec a dit bon bah
c'est bon pour tout le monde
si tu m'emmènes faire un tour en bateau
[Applaudissements]